The mind is a brain that's conscious.
Consciousness is a synonym for
subjectivity,
and there's a conceptual gap between
subjectivity and objective observation,
which is what science is.
I would actually maintain that there is
no scientific way to demonstrate that an
entity is conscious.
It's only a parent to itself,
and my prediction is that we will.
This is an objective prediction.
We will come to accept entities that are
not biological,
uh,
as conscious,
but it's not going to be okay machines
on the right side of the room.
Humans on the left,
if you talked to your biological human,
that they will have lots of non
biological processes going on in their
body and brain.
Those computers will be out in the
cloud.
So the thinking of that person isn't
even just in their body and brain.
Even in the non biological portion,
it's out on the cloud.
So it's going to be all mixed up.
It's not going to be a clear distinction
between human and machine.
The bottom line is we are one human
machine civilization.
This technology is already expanded who
we are,
and it's going to go into high gear when
we get to the steep part of the
exponential.